the ayatollah khomeini is still still on
twitter hamas is still on twitter who a
part of their charter is not by the way
not just the eradication of israel
all jews and we're also we're talking
about anti-semitic
hate crimes that could potentially be
inspired by donald trump here at home
look that is an editorial decision in
other words if twitter says
this is too far for donald trump to be
on twitter
or youtube or facebook that means that
they are consciously saying
hamas is not too far the ayatollah not
too far and that
cannot come with the same legal
protections
of a platform like at t or verizon
that is an editorial decision just like
the new york times
just like the washington post and just
like youtube saying
you can't praise an officer for saving a
girl's life from being stabbed we can't
allow it
can't allow that to go on
well i think you know crowder i don't
think i'm enlightening you when i tell
you that you know that what this really
of course is about is that you are
changing minds you have an
absolutely extraordinarily huge channel
how many people did you have on election
night before they took you down
how many people were watching oh gosh i
don't uh i don't know it was at any
given
point something like six hundred
thousand cumulative it was like 16
million you know and look
i hate doing this because you know no
you know that we've had people who do i
get it it's not it's not just
it's not just blowing you up but but the
point is yeah you talk about billions of
players
why are they always trying to take out
tucker i mean we know why it's not about
tucker
it's about the people yeah it's about
billions of plays billions of plays
across our platform and if you include
it's it's one of those things and i say
it on my knees i'm so grateful for it
and i know that all this could go away
and i could annoy people and they don't
want to watch the show
that's fine but it needs to occur on an
honest platform an important thing too a
lot of people think this doesn't affect
them they go
well he's a dick like guilty however
if you're a business owner you want to
conduct business now in the 21st century
this is a town square 230 not even
withstanding but you know this
youtube twitter facebook they co they go
to business owners they come to us and
say advertise with us
you get to keep the subscribers you gain
if you advertise you get to keep the
followers that you gain right if you
want to open up a shop and you don't
advertise online
you haven't got a shot and this is an
issue of dishonest business practices if
they are choosing
not only politically winners and losers
as it relates to business they can do
this with
anyone i'm pro-business i'm anti-fraud
and with youtube right now here's the
issue you have what
you have community guidelines okay
that's one set of rules
that's set by youtube youtube says
advertiser friendly guidelines are set
by sponsors well i've tried to be a
sponsor and i've advertised i've never
once been requested hey where would you
like to advertise your content
matter of fact they've precluded me from
doing it and i've been a content creator
where i can't accept
certain sponsors and then they have a
third category which no one really knows
isn't defined which is borderline
and we don't know who determines that
they're all determined by youtube at the
end of the day yes
yes borderline dave rubin the
radicalization the uh the third reich
mr rubin you know the funny thing about
that article in the new york times about
the radicalization to the to the far
right is yeah you and defranco and
jordan peterson and milton friedman
who's a real nutbag
uh you guys were all on the cover of the
print one you had to open to page three
to get my picture except it was a huge
picture of my face under something like
leading them to the alt-right
my dad had no idea my dad had no idea
but wait
putting aside the specifics of the
politics and i get it people
people know that you don't want the
government involved and they know they
get the difference between platform and
publisher and all that stuff
just on the pure like you're suing
youtube side of this it can't be that
much
fun i think i sort of asked you about
that last time like like the idea that
you're going
up against goliath like it's not like a
great pleasure
no it's it's not something that i want
to do at all and i wish it could be
settled and i wish that we could have
had answers and look i just want to do
my show
unlike you know with joe rogan for
example in spotify uh something like 40
something episodes were removed and it
was done in the dead of night look
this is why we haven't do it though just
for the record i mean right
now to be clear that what happened with
the vox apocalypse
um there were conversations behind the
scenes which hopefully i have to be
careful as to what i discuss what i
don't but we were very public we said
look
we have to remove 30-something videos
from youtube because they may be
borderline even though they're not
violating policy
these are available at mug club didn't
want to do it it wasn't a violation of
policies but i was saying hey
this is an act of good faith it's
youtube sandbox they can determine the
rules and we were transparent about it
saying
off platform at mug club and you know
these might have been radical views
like life begins at you know conception
or something like that something that
should never be permissible on youtube
we were very straightforward with it our
entire catalog has been audited
at great length and now these are new
potential violations that may or may not
exist look we've had to reinvent this is
why i say
i'm about to be a father of two i employ
i think it's 14
people right now um and that you know
this these are the first people that i
think of when i when i get up and the
last people i think of when i go to
sleep
because they don't have the control that
i do in fighting youtube and making
these decisions my decisions affect them
we've had to fundamentally change our
business model
we figured out oh wait if you search
stephen crowder change my mind abortion
you find an old pbs video with 400 views
we can no longer rely on search or
browse
okay we're going to focus on not just
subscriptions but notifications
wait notifications no longer really work
so we moved to a live show
we can't edit because we go live and we
just tell people and it still isn't mug
club
weekdays at 10 a.m eastern to the point
where it doesn't matter if we don't show
up in search
it doesn't matter if we don't show up
and browse it doesn't matter if
subscriptions or notifications work
we have a baseline of millions of
viewers who will tune in every day
and we're always at the top of the
youtube live page right they can't
control it because it's more popular
than other programs
i think this is sort of the last
decision they can make
considering that we've consistently
adapted to rules that are not applied to
anyone else
i am so i am such a pacifist i sow him a
conflict avoider
but my belief is you avoid avoid avoid
avoid avoid and then if you have to
engage in a conflict
you make it as swift and effective as
you possibly can
and i wish that we hadn't crossed that
line i wish that youtube hadn't
i hope they do the right thing and i
don't want to do this but we will
have you ever met susan the ceo of
youtube have you ever met her
never which is bizarre when you see her
mentioning me by name at the recode
conference with uh someone who works for
vox interviewing her
it's it's surreal it really is was that
the interview where they said dave rubin
is the gateway drug to guys like steven
crowder i think that might have been it
is that i'm not kidding i'm not kidding
there was one talk
i don't know if it was that one you were
that you were the molly to my mdma i
don't know maybe
it could be but it's bizarre for me
whenever you do molly first or
well i honestly i don't know basic [ __ ]
like i said i don't know
um let me ask you one more thing because
we're just doing this quick because i
just wanted to get word out about this
because it's important because thank you
appreciate it the truth is i mean
we're friends but the truth is if you go
down then
you're right it's the floodgates on
everybody but so let me just ask you
this to finish
do you sort of feel like this with you
and youtube
is just directly connected to everything
going on in society right now which is
that all the things that guys like us
have been screaming about and warning
against
it's all here it's at the doorstep
that's sort of what you were saying like
it's just like
it's all just arrived and whether it's
crowder being taken off youtube or
attacking people in the streets or
changing every norm in our
political discourse it's all here
look people need to understand the world
that we live laws are being suspended
what do i mean
right now you have people complaining
like there are laws in florida that if
it'll just make it easy for you to run
over protesters i go ah it's like oh
it's like what we're talking about our
riots we're talking about people have
been dragged out of their cars
hold on is it illegal to congregate in
the middle of a freeway
it is it's illegal but but we've just
decided we don't enforce those laws so
we've decided to suspend the law and
instead
turn americans into criminals americans
with vehicles
americans who legally purchase firearms
we've decided to turn them into
criminals now maybe americans
who speak out against policies turn them
into criminals i will
we'll say this look with with with
youtube um
you go back to the idea of publisher
platform i don't think it's ever been
more clear than
uh to use twitter as an example i mean
donald president donald trump wasn't
really on youtube
they remove a sitting president for
saying fight like hell
and look i don't care i don't even think
it's controversial anyone who acts as a
fight like hell has not been a phrase
that has been used
as a colloquialism for is being
intellectually dishonest that's why we
sell the fight like hell shirt at
crowder shop um it's a term that i've
seen waters has said worse
yes she has said worse and she's done
worse look at the size of those pupils
uh so he was removed though twitter said
that's a bridge too far okay
the ayatollah khamenei is still still on
twitter hamas is still on twitter who a
part of their charter is not by the way
not just the eradication of israel
all jews and we're also we're talking
about anti-semitic
hate crimes that could potentially be
inspired by donald trump here at home
look that is an editorial decision in
other words if twitter says
this is too far for donald trump to be
on twitter
or youtube or facebook that means that
they are consciously saying
hamas is not too far the ayatollah not
too far and
that cannot come with the same legal
protections
of a platform like a t or verizon
that is an editorial decision just like
the new york times
just like the washington post and just
like youtube saying
you can't praise an officer for saving a
girl's life from being stabbed we can't
allow it can't allow that to go on
isn't it a weird position that for guys
like us like i do think about it often
where i'm like man
if if youtube servers blew up but i
think about it usually more
related to twitter if twitter just
ceased to exist tomorrow and
all the data was destroyed all of the
followings all of that stuff like
it feels to me and i actually don't mean
this on the youtube side on the twitter
side specifically
like the world would be better that's a
very weird thing
for guys like to think yeah i know but
you know i don't know about youtube
because where would people find
their hardcore pornography we have found
by the way
just just so people know hardcore born
on youtube
yes yes and there's also guys who play
uh listen we've done this on the show
dickerdildo it's two uh
two uh uh homosexual gentlemen who put
up a sheet and played dick or dildo
where the guy is facing the camera
and he has to guess if it's a dick or a
dildo by the way the answer is always
dick
it's never dildo this is on youtube and
it's not even age restricted
now i will say this i know look and
people know that i don't i'm not trying
to shock people
when we cite facts when we give out
references they're all publicly
available
on the website i don't know any other
show that does that you're talking about
on average
anywhere from 40 to 60 per day we make a
joke
it may offend people you may not find it
funny you may not like it but you have
to acknowledge that it's a joke and the
standard can't be
does it offend you the standard that
youtube has to apply and i'm going to
use some language here because i'm
quoting directly stephen colbert and
samantha b
is did steven do anything did steven
crowder say anything more offensive than
referring to a sitting president's mouth
as putin's [ __ ] holster did he say did
he bully anyone worse than samantha bee
with a national platform on on
television referring to the first lady
as a feckless [ __ ]
nope that's the standard that has to be
applied equally not if it offends
somebody
and because that's not the kind of
language or spirit of the comedy that i
would ever use
facts and information notwithstanding if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about
comedy instead of the non-stop yelling
you get everywhere else check out our
comedy playlist and if you want to watch
full interviews on a variety
of topics check out our full episode
playlist they're both
right over here and to get notified of
all future videos be sure to subscribe
and click the notification bell